most people most Champions do not have
something that you do not have they lack
something that you have for a champion
in the Physical Realm a lot of times
it's they don't have an off switch they
just keep going and so to the same
degree you probably do things every
single day that you should not be doing
and so what I want to introduce to you
is a concept of the anti-routine as the
most productive routine that is humanly
possible for you to accomplish what you
want number one is obviously just
shifting the perspective of I need to do
more things and I need to add more
things to my routine when in fact you
need to stop doing things that you're
currently doing all that remains is the
work to be done priorities mean two
things cannot be equally important when
you work on something if I spend 30
minutes on both things and I say this
one's more important than this one I can
say that but that's not reality because
I basically just said they were both
important which means neither of them
are which is why most people cannot get
done because they cannot say no you need
to have a routine of saying no an
anti-routine and that is the thing
that's going to feel those outsized
Returns on productivity you can't do two
things with different levels of
importance it's either important or it's
not important so if you say this is the
priority then it means you do not do
other things besides that thing that is
how it is a priority that is how you
literally prioritize hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggled
to stay afloat I quit my business
partner and the thing that kept me going
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the 10 habits
that successful people run daily
enjoy
habit number two is build perseverance
with Tom bilyu do you know how depressed
you have to be to kneel on the floor
instead of sitting on the couch like
where you're just oh God everything in
your life sucks I have knelt on the
floor before the couch and wanted to cry
just wished that I was a crier because I
could not get the feeling out of my body
and the only thing in those moments that
keeps me going is
being so obsessed with my goal that when
I focus on that glowing hot Ember at the
center of my life
it's enough
but if it isn't enough you will quit
this is why almost everybody quits
at everything yeah they all give up a
New Year's resolution they all quit
the big goal in their life they all quit
I'm getting emotional right now people
quit dude it's so heartbreaking
my mission in life is to get people to
understand that they're having a
biological experience so they'll do the
things they need to do to not quit
to just
have the juice to keep going to have a
habit
system
[Music]
that makes the feeling you need to feel
to keep going visceral
you feel it in your gut
like nobody could tell you to stop
because you really are excited like the
things that I'm excited about I'm
legitimately excited and people can't
stop me from being excited like if you
ask me like right now we're recording
this in the middle of the most bear
Market of bear markets even people in
web 3 now are like turning on each other
it's super weird but you couldn't make
me not be excited about it because I've
spent so much time thinking about what
the technology is going to let us do and
how I'm going to leverage that to have
the impact that I want to have in the
world and quite frankly just
telling stories is so exciting to me and
so when I talk about it I feel the thing
I want to feel so now if I just start
telling somebody what my vision is I get
re-excited I don't do it on purpose
anymore the first six months a year
whatever was so intentional
like having to remind myself this is
what I'm doing is why it's Society ah
repeat repeat repeat repeat
but now if somebody asks me about it and
I just start talking about it I
can't help but get amped and
enthusiastic and so something that you
and I say a lot that we stole from David
Goggins or David Goggins graced us with
to carry the boats I'll carry all of web
3 if I have to I will drag them into the
future I don't need them to support me
anymore I don't need the energy to come
back from them
you have to whatever the thing is that
somebody wants it has to be that
visceral where and
may I take us into deeper waters you
have to be able to create an image in
your mind
that makes you feel so aggressive
I like I I rightly get accused of
speaking in war language and the first
time somebody said that to me I felt
guilty
I was like oh that's kind of gross maybe
I shouldn't do that
and for a long time I was like yeah I
need to find a better way to say that
I'm Unapologetic now I imagine myself as
a warrior covered in the blood of those
who are trying to stop me from having
the impact that I want to have on the
world now I don't mean that literally I
am not going to kill violence is a
mistake but having that level of
intensity to bring people together to
help people and I do admit I do that
imagery is very evocative and so I very
much think of myself with a sword in my
hands dripping with the blood of the
weak people who are trying to stop me
will
that gets me going right now I look you
can actually see the hair standing up on
my arm
that gets me I'm sweating that gets me
going and so I feed that image into my
mind so that in those moments I'm like
no no like I can lean into that dark
energy I can keep myself going but I do
it so much it is so visceral it is so
real that I feel it when when I need it
it's there and I can think of myself
with that sword having to just go
through all the obstacles covered in
blood hearing the Lamentations of those
who would try to oppose me
can only imagine what people are
thinking right now but that works it
works and if people can internalize that
level of intensity for the beautiful
thing they want to do I want to
reinforce that it is a uplifting thing I
want to bring people together
but
it's hard and so you have to be able to
generate that level of intensity
to get to the other side to keep going
to
to overcome the second law of
Thermodynamics which is that all things
move towards chaos entropy
what's the answer you have to pour
energy into the system and you have to
pour that energy into the system in a
very specific guided way
if when people are trying to like tear
you down or just like forget that
because I'm not a victim when things are
just hard when I'm an idiot and I keep
making mistakes when I'm embarrassed
how do I have the energy to keep going I
have to see myself as that Warrior I
have to be willing to be covered in my
own blood I have to be willing to keep
pushing and going and being able to
channel that Goggins and to find that
gear and to shift into it when I'm on my
knees in front of the couch because I
don't have the emotional fortitude to
sit on the couch
I've been there at that moment I have to
be able to channel that energy how about
number three is align your action with
your goals with Mel Robbins successful
people
Act before they feel ready
they act like the person they want to be
instead of the person that they feel
like today I got my start
in the media business this is my first
taste of the media business in 2008 by
hosting a local call-in radio show on
Saturday mornings in Boston
Massachusetts I did not know that yes I
paid for my kids braces by reading
Invisalign ads for a dentist in Boston
that I still go to shout out to Dr
ronkin he did not pay me to say that
that was a long time ago
um
and I love that show Tom I freaking
loved it why did I have a radio show
I'll tell you why because for those of
you that have seen my first appearance
here with Tom this was the period in my
life where Chris's restaurant was going
off the rails we were nearly a million
dollars in debt there were liens on our
house I had lost my job I needed money
that's why I had that job it paid 25 an
hour for two hours every Saturday and I
felt like the world's worst mom because
every other parent was at Town soccer
somebody else thank you thank you thank
you to The Graces for driving our kids
they were taking our kids to soccer for
us while I could go Host this radio show
and Chris was doing whatever he could to
save the business that show is a
lifeline I would talk to real people
every single day it made me feel
connected to people it made me it gave
me a sense of purpose I loved the
intimacy of it and so Evers and that
show eventually grew
and it became syndicated and then I won
something called The Gracie award for my
coverage of trayvon's murder and that
got CNN's attention and they called me
and said hey you know we would love to
have you be a legal analyst here and so
that then got me on CNN and ever since I
left radio I have missed it
and I've been wanting to get back to it
and in the back of my mind especially
after I wrote the five second rule I
kept thinking I need to launch podcast I
need to launch a podcast I love podcast
I I have I need to do this and
it mattered so much to me I was so like
drawn to it Tom that I think that
oftentimes when the dream is such a call
the excuses match the desire for it
right and it was never the right time it
just never I just talked myself out of
it over and over and over and over and
over again and so finally like 18 months
ago I literally woke up one morning I
had my own wake-up call and I'm like
that's it like you're gonna let another
10 years go by
unless you make a decision
to get started how did you get started
so you decide you're going to do it and
like take people into the weeds a bit
because yeah okay this is where I think
people go off the rails they they're
sitting at home thinking yeah I want to
start a podcast as well and I want to
hear because I know that you end up
doing it on a way more professional
stage but walk people through what who'd
you call was it a relationship that you
built 20 years ago I want people to
follow that yeah so first things first
I went to my friend Google
honest to God even though I know Tom and
I know Lisa I was too embarrassed to ask
you
because you know you guys are like out
here with all these millions of subs and
you've like been doing the show for a
while and same thing with Lewis like you
know you and I have some amazing friends
and oftentimes I find that going to
people that already seem like they're at
the top of the top
that's intimidating because it it
magnifies at least for somebody who's
got a lot of insecurity like me it
magnifies
the distance between where you are
starting and where somebody is years
down the road because part of your
um genius Tom is that like it's easy to
look at what Tom's built and forget the
fact that this dude has been studying
film since he went to USC for film
school this guy is a insanely successful
entrepreneur that's bringing all of that
Sweat Equity and learning to the table
this is somebody that's dedicated
himself to like years of figuring this
out and sampling and editing and so I
personally find that when you go to
somebody that's already there it can be
a little discouraging so I went to
Google and I'm like how do you start a
podcast honest to God because I'm smart
enough to know it's different than radio
and I didn't even know what equipment
people have I didn't know anything about
okay do you go to like how do you put a
podcast up
do you put it everywhere I don't know
like is there a form that you put the
title on and the captions and then do
you send it somewhere like I know how to
upload a video to YouTube I know how to
but I don't know anything about this
market and so I went to Google
um You're gonna laugh at me but I bought
a course about podcasting not laughing
at all
um I uh studied a bunch of videos about
the type of equipment that people bought
um I then just started stalking people
that are doing it and I started to say
my myself okay
what does somebody that already has a
podcast what do they do that I'm not
currently doing and so the first step is
obviously learn about it identify a
group of people that serve as what I
call your lights on the path and so
lights on the path are people that are
anywhere from one step ahead of you
to 10 years ahead of you and these are
all people that can guide you forward if
you study what they did and most of them
by the way we live in the most magical
period of time you have no excuse
for not walking toward what you want I
realize it may be harder for some of us
with mental health issues I realize that
not everybody starts at the same uh
starting line because of bias and all
kinds of things that can happen to
people but the bottom line is through
your actions and attitude you can create
anything you want rule number four is
Master self-discipline with Marissa peer
I meet people all the time that really
struggle with self-discipline because
they have this interesting belief it's
something you're born with and that's
not true no baby is born with discipline
in fact they find it very hard to do
that discipline is something you require
it's like a muscle if you work it it
gets better so I'm going to tell you
some absolute secrets of people who
appear to be naturally disciplined they
know I've worked with many many Olympic
athletes they don't go yay it's snow
going to get up and go out and train
today they have to keep saying I want
that Olympic medal
and this is the price I'm going to pay
to get the Olympic medal so before you
begin to adopt self-discipline take a
minute and think what do I want what do
I really really want and then answer
another question what
price would I pay to get what I want do
you want a great relationship well you
have to go out you can't sit at home
you've got to go out and interact with
people you want a great job you've got
to go for some interviews
but there are some actually keys that
vary very
disciplined people have and here is the
most important one and this would change
your life if you do it and I had to make
myself do this it was not natural at all
you must do what you don't want to do
first people who are hugely successful
do this they do the thing they hate
first of all I worked with somebody who
was morbidly obese and I said you know
you have to work out when I hate working
out you know I'm heavy it's really
uncomfortable not only have you got to
do it you got to do it first and I had
to do that too you see if you don't like
going to the gym and you go I'll go
later then something happens the phone
rings you eat something you think oh
it's too late now
when you go first you think later oh
I've been I went to the gym first I like
a winner you've got to make a very
difficult call you've got to ring
someone who owes you money or confront
someone that you don't want to confront
and you wait and all day it's hanging
over your head making you feel so bad
when you do it first you feel like a
winner
because people who have discipline do
this they do the thing they do not want
to do first and I want you to start
saying that I was giving a speech
recently and the guy who came on after
me said you know I kept hearing my voice
about going Marissa said do what you
don't want to do first is that that has
changed my entire business life and all
my staff remember that too what do we
not want to do what's the worst job
let's do that first and get it out of
the way so that is secret one to having
incredible
self-discipline tell yourself make
yourself do what you don't want to do
first and of course in the beginning
this will be what you do but you know
what will happen it starts to become who
you are it becomes easy it becomes
seamless it's a bit like putting lenses
in your eye it feels seriously odd to
suddenly Jam your finger in your eye but
if you you do every day comes easy
because that's how habits are formed you
make a habit
and then your habits make you so make
your habits amazing so you've got habit
one here is habit two take action every
single day in the direction of your
goals and that doesn't mean work for 10
hours a day but even on a Saturday or a
Sunday if you're building your business
spend five minutes
answering one email making one call
because that's what winners do they
don't have a day off when they are on
their way to success they take action
every single day in that direction of
their goals and here's point three and
it possibly is the most important point
of all delay gratification delay the
reward you see years ago we went to work
and our boss would go hey good job you
did really well today but now a lot of
us don't have a boss we work for
ourselves we work from home you may be a
coach or a marketer
you don't have a boss praising you
without praise your praise muscle never
really grows what happens when you work
for yourself is halfway through you stop
and you do something and what you have
to do in the morning is go right I I
love my cappuccino but I'm going to do
something first make six calls send out
an email then the cappuccino is my
reward and in the evening you've got to
think of your dinner and your TV as a
reward I'm going to reward myself
and you see if you see as a reward it
makes you work better
it's a big problem that we take the
reward first I'm going to eat that have
a nice dinner and I'll do all the other
stuff later and you know what happens
later never comes so you have to now do
what we naturally do as parents we see
when you finish your homework you can go
out to play at school you have work and
then playtime a parent will say tidy up
your room and then you might have ice
cream so we are naturally wired to take
the reward after the work but what's
happened is we now give ourselves the
reward before the work and then we don't
feel any inspiration to do the work
so I promise you if you adopt these
three habits it will change your life do
what you don't want to do first take
action every day in the direction of
your goals no matter how small the
action is the smallness doesn't matter
what matters is you are wiring your mind
coding your mind firing into your mind
the habits of natural winners
and then you'll be a winner and who
cares if it's unnatural that's not
important and point three of course is
delay gratification delay your reward
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is write a
journal with Jim quick when I was 18
years old and I was really struggling I
was a freshman in college I couldn't
keep up I didn't know how to learn and I
didn't know how to focus I didn't know
how to study I didn't know how to to
think so a friend of mine said hey
before you quit school because that's
the point I was at I was ready to tell
my family I was going to quit college
said why don't you get some perspective
and we talk about the power of
perspective with our thinking that when
you could change your point of view you
could look at something with a new Fresh
eyes and take a new approach and not be
stuck to a limited amount of options so
I go to visit the family and the family
is pretty pretty well off and the father
walks me around his property before
dinner and asked me a very innocent
question which is the worst question you
could ask me at that time says Jim Howe
school right and I just break down in
front of this complete stranger and tell
them my whole story The Boy with a
broken brain learning challenges I'm
ready to quit school and he says stop
why are you in school what do you want
to be what do you want to do what do you
want to have what do you want to ask
share and notice that his process for
achievement is asking me new questions
because ask a new question get a new
answer changing perspective place people
allows me a new point of view so you see
these principles always showing up with
quality thinkers and when I go to answer
them what I want to do and be and have
and share with the world he says stop
and he pulls out of his pocket a journal
like a notebook and he tears out a
couple of sheets and makes me write it
down and this is the principle I want to
talk to you about in this lesson so if
you want to transform your thinking you
need to be able to transform your
ability to write things down and make
something physical because the act of
taking the invisible your imagination
your goals your vision and making it a
reality one of the best things you could
do is to write it down and make a
physical motion so you actually created
something from your thought from your
thinking into reality so that's the
first step up so I wrote down my my
bucket list of all the things I wanted
to be do have and share and this became
my drive this became my why why to learn
why to read why to do well in school and
that's why we always talk about those
three questions asking yourself how can
I use this why must I use this when will
I use this so you'll notice in history
some of the most incredible Geniuses men
and women throughout history kept
journals right the journals of Leonardo
da Vinci Marie Curie Einstein they're
invaluable they are they are Priceless
and the question I've always wondered is
is it because they're Geniuses that
they're journaling all the time and
they're making notes all the time or is
it because they're journaling all the
time that they become Geniuses I would
argue for the latter so in this session
I'm going to share with you exactly how
I capture and create notes and how I
Journal each day to capture my thoughts
if you want expert high level thinking
you need to be able to capture this in a
journal so the first thing you need to
do is you need to get a journal or get a
notebook and I'm very big into
physically writing your notes and
writing in your Journal as opposed to
typing it out now living in a digital
age I see the convenience of being able
to share and store information digitally
I'm going to ask you through this
process to actually hand write it and
there's certain advantages to
handwriting your notes and handwriting
your journals first of all as you're
taking notes as we're having this
conversation you can maybe type as fast
as somebody can speak but you certainly
can't write that fast so by writing it
down it forces you to think about what
you're listening to and you start to
filter and qualify the information
before you write it down because you
can't possibly write as fast as someone
can speak so in studies that have tested
people from handwriting notes and typing
out notes the people that hand write
notes did better on test scores maybe
for this very reason that they're
capturing only the important parts
because the worst way of taking notes
actually was full transcripts or full
dictation now the question is how do you
handwrite notes what I would suggest is
this you have a piece of paper take your
pen and put a line right down the middle
of the page so on the left side you're
writing down the lessons on the right
side you can be creative and ask the
three questions how can I use this and
then write it down why must I use it and
then write it down when will I use it
and write it down these are wonderful
ways to not only take notes but also to
make notes and by making notes you
create a feedback loop and this is very
good for advanced thinkers to train your
thinking ability you're taking your
thoughts you're putting it on paper
you're organizing them and and it allows
you to use critical thinking skills and
some of the skills you're going to learn
in this program right in front of you so
you have your notebook your capturing
and you're creating and I would have a
dedicated notebook for this program and
on top of having a notebook a dedicated
notebook for your learning in this
process you could also have a journal
some people have a life journal some
people have a dream journal in this
journal you could capture your your
day-to-days your Visions the things that
you're struggling with the things that
you're reflecting upon so one of the
benefits of having a journal is you go
back and re-read and review some of
those entries I have journals that date
back years and years and years and it's
wonderful to be able to revisit it gives
you this thing called perspective
perspective is a very powerful tool when
it comes to your learning when it comes
to your thinking rule number six is tell
your own story with Lucy tempea here's
what I wanted to to share with you it
hit me
um that
I am exactly where I'm supposed to be
exactly where I'm supposed to be
I might not like where I am
I not like how I got here
but I am exactly where I'm supposed to
be
and the reason that's an empowering
realization is because once I realize
I'm exactly where I'm supposed to be
then the question becomes
[Music]
what am I expected to learn
do or become
to move me from where I am now
to where I desire to be
right
there are some of you watching this
who don't like the place you were in
you've lost the business
you've lost a job
you've lost a home
you maybe lost friendships
loved ones a lover
a family a marriage a partnership
there are some of you who are watching
this and you have lost a lot
and it's hard it's hard
the way through it is through it
you are exactly what you're supposed to
be
[Music]
once you realize this
how you approach the next few stages of
your life changes
so the first question to ask yourself
is if I don't like where I am how did I
get here
right you are so you are where you're
supposed to be
but if you don't like it how did you get
here
and if you're not aware of the decisions
you took
or continuing to take
of the way you show up
in Partnerships friendships
relationships
of the way you think about yourself and
about the world
of the way you speak to yourself about
yourself to others about others
and of the way you live your life
if you're not aware of that and you're
not aware of your gaps are you're going
to repeat exactly the same mistakes
so the trick then is to slow yourself
down and go I don't like
what I am
what do I need to change
where do I need to improve
and that's how you get from where you
are to where you desire to be
[Music]
the second thing to realize is
that the best lessons are often the most
bitter
so the question for you to ask yourself
is have you learned the lessons you need
to learn
to make sure
that you don't repeat the errors you've
made in the past
have you learned those lessons
and then the third thing to ask yourself
is
if your life
I saw this uh I saw this beautiful quote
um
at my stock broker's office it said it
was like one of these you don't like
these quotes on the wall that's like
written text on the wall and the quote
said if your life were a movie and you
were the main character
and this was the opening scene
how would the rest of the movie play out
full stop
do that
I was like wow that that clarifies it
right so
whatever you want to achieve in future
wherever you want to go however you want
to get there if your life right now was
a movie and you were the main character
and this part of your life was the
opening scene think about Will Smith and
the pursuit of happiness that very
opening scene where he's bought those
terrible x-ray machines and computer
machines they stacked up walls high in
his home he's battling to keep his
marriage together he can barely provide
for his own that's the opening part of
the movie if that's where you are and
that's what your life looks like and you
don't like where you are you are where
you're supposed to be
now how do you get to where you want to
be
I say you are where you're supposed to
be is this supposed to part means that
there is something you need to learn so
that you're not there again
see you will always find yourself
resident at the place where you are not
learning lessons
because you're not growing beyond that
point so learn the lessons that are
keeping you stuck at that level and move
Beyond it
but if you were Will Smith in that movie
and this is the opening scene of your
life
what does the rest of the movie look
like
okay
now go do that
so go be your own superhero
go be your own rock star
go be your own
oscar-nominated winner in the movie that
is your life
in the character that is your story rule
number seven is be productive with Dean
graziosi there's a difference between
being busy
and being productive we all know that
you're like oh that's brilliant Dean but
you know that already but a lot of times
I do it I don't know about you I still
slip back into being doing busy work and
I feel like I had an accomplishing day
and then I look I'm like no you just
found a way to keep your brain busy but
did you actually move the needle in your
life did you move towards a bigger
future did you grow did you become a
better version of you today than
yesterday and I really need to measure
that but again if it's a complicated app
like write in what I ate for lunch and
how many calories it was you don't do it
so here's what I I
so I'm going to give it to you the way I
do it there's three types of things that
I write down in my journal and kind of
three types of things that we do on a
regular basis right
so there are things in your life and
this is what you need to write down and
some of you can text it in here which I
love when you guys do that
um or not text it post in here there's
things that you must do right so let's
label it one through three there's
things you must do so what are some
things you must do
you might want to do them but they're a
must like at three o'clock at 2 40 the
days I have my kids I must it's just a
part of my life I ain't missing it until
they tell me I can't do anymore at 2 40
I must go pick up my kids from school
yes I could send my assistant yes my
wife can go yes their mom can go but for
me that's a must I must go there right
uh there's other stuff I must go I must
go if you saw that other training I had
to get oh I cut myself shaving today but
the other one I had like three
pre-cancers I had to get burned off
there's must things of like going to a
doctor and making sure you're
maintaining yourself there's must I
don't mean it in a bad way there's good
must and bad musk picking up my kids and
must I love going to the gym in the
morning I don't know if I always love it
but I must go to the gym every morning
because it puts my head in the right
space so there's must do stuff so you
kind of just gotta label that and always
always always question must do stuff
like I must go hang out with my friends
on Thursday night because it's how we
all Bond well maybe that's what you must
do in your 20s and your 30s
I don't know every time I go there we
don't talk about anything positive we
talk about what's wrong with the country
the world the president my family my
friends I end up talking [ __ ] about my
boyfriend or my girlfriend like I don't
know if that's a must anymore so I would
question all the musts but if you must
do Monday morning meetings with the team
that's a must but but
again oh this is all stuff I write
everything in my journalist so I'm I'm
gonna try to tie this all together right
when you get the journal you get that 20
minute training I give you the Tactical
this I'm giving you the heart behind the
Simplicity of why this has moved the
needle so much in my life right so
what are some of the musts you do
they're just on the calendar no matter
what and I would really analyze are they
a must can you delete them
are they a must and if they are can you
make them better like if you're going to
do a Monday morning meeting
can you show up and actually move the
needle in your life like this is all
going to come down to what the journal
says is what are the most important
needle movers in your life because we
get stuck in minutia we get stuck in the
hypnotic rhythm Dale Carnegie used to
call we get stuck in the hypnotic rhythm
of a day we get stuck in a hypnot a
rhythm of a weekly routine of a monthly
routine and you don't realize it's like
wow I've been doing the same workout oh
I've been getting the same coffee oh
I've been handling the meetings the same
way oh I've been picking my kids up and
I'm kind of not in the best mood in the
same way it's like
screw that time to shake this [ __ ] up
like how do I improve picking my kids up
like some days I'll have a crazy day
I'll pick my kids up like yeah I'm just
waiting in this line I'm like no I'm
gonna Park and when they come out
they're going to see my big smile I
don't care what I feel like I'm shaking
this up today I'm like I must pick them
up because I want to but I'm going to do
it different like I'll show up sometimes
we have weekly meetings for the teams
and it's very this is what we did this
week this is what we accomplished we
took what we measure we look at our
scorecard and when they do that and some
days I'll just kind of like yo what's up
everybody I want to tell you about this
story with my kid and I'll just shake it
up and I watch their faces it just shuck
up if we're gonna do a must Shake It Up
and then really analyze those must right
okay second part so it's something you
must do and then there's busy work
okay now this stuff gets written in here
I I don't want to like just totally dog
it be calling it busy work like you
shouldn't do it but this is stuff that's
habit driven I want you to identify
things that are habit driven this is
busy work but this is stuff if you're
currently working in a job there's busy
stuff you do all day and you have to
that's how you get a paycheck that's how
you help the company grow that's how you
do what you do if you own your own
company there's stuff that's busy work I
did busy work all morning legit I was on
the phone closing a partnership deal uh
for an hour talking about the contract
talking about each person's roles and
responsibilities all that kind of stuff
that's kind of busy work to me I kind of
hate it but
I have to do it
but once again
you got to analyze the busy work the the
repetitive stuff that you have to do not
the stuff you must do that's different
the re the busy work you have to analyze
is it busy work that actually
keeps the company stable or keeps your
job or keeps your family or keeps that
stable
um
but doesn't really move the needle in
your life and then there's some busy
work that come on it's time to let it go
and stop doing it literally find a
different way hire a virtual assistant
in the Philippines for five dollars an
hour hire a an intern a college intern
at 15 bucks an hour and get them to pick
up your dry cleaning and run the errands
and go to Home Depot and build the signs
or help you with your graphics go to
fiverr.com go to 99designs and get your
logos done stop going online and playing
with your logos for for you know 10
hours and in between that you're
stopping by to see what the Kardashians
did I'm not knocking the Kardashians and
most of you don't watch but some of us
know more about the Kardashians than we
know about how to move the needle
forward in our life about marketing
right don't go online say I want to look
at all these other sites on how they're
doing it and all of a sudden you're like
oh my God Bruce Jenner did that like
maybe that's not topic I don't watch the
news so maybe that's not hot in the news
anymore but I'm sharing this stuff
because
um
I watched so many people get sucked into
busy work that's not a needle mover and
the reason I'm sharing this and how I
hope this I hope you're loving this
because I'm just sharing it real and raw
this little Journal changes my life
because I write it all down I write down
what I must do I write down my busy work
and in no form I'm just telling you mine
mine is sloppy like this is just what I
write every single day of my life
everything goes in here and the busy
work in here the must do stuff and when
I get the chance every two weeks and
we'll get to it to kind of bring all of
it Forward on the on the sheet that in
my journal it's three columns it's uh
the needle movers and most important
it's the what I need to do today this
week and this month and then what should
I stop doing when I kind of take all my
notes from like a week or two and I
bring them form and kind of condense
them I get to go why would I think I
must do that
I must not do that anymore or that busy
work yeah that that's the foundation my
company I don't love it and someday I
want someone to do it for me but right
now I got to do it that's busy work that
must be done let's just call it busy
work it's effective work I don't want
busy to have a negative connotation on
some of it but maybe it's effective work
don't love it gotta do it let me find a
way to like it let me find a way to like
it but then there's also busy work
that you're like
um
I don't need to do that anymore that
busy work doesn't do anything for me God
the universe my next level next version
of me my Evolution my growth making 2020
the best year of my life like that busy
work doesn't do crap for me it's got to
go all right you feeling it now the
first was what must do stuff second is
busy work kind of habits you gotta watch
those habits there's good habits that
keep your keep your company growing this
busy work that doesn't do crap for
anybody not your company not your
business not the job you're in not your
career none of it doesn't get your first
Mastermind Workshop book whatever it is
you want out of life to the next level
just doesn't do it and the third and
this I'm going to tie this all together
guys I'm gonna tie this all together the
third is the most important part that's
the needle Movers
that is the the things that you can work
on that are sometimes scary
that actually move the needle in your
life that's how your career Leap Frogs
that's how you get the business off the
ground that's how you take the business
that's doing okay and you scale it to
another level and this is the part that
really
um that really and I'm gonna I'm gonna
jump ahead here this is the part that
has changed my life and this is a part
why journaling whether mine a pad a
white pad like this or anybody's I'm I'm
just this is talking about uh
just getting it done today that's where
I know
that I pass people I work with everybody
says how do you stay ahead how are you
always Cutting Edge how have you been
relevant in social media and TV and in
this space for 21 years how have you
been an entrepreneur how might you read
the underdog Advantage I go more
personal in here on failure stories and
success stories I've share stuff in here
I've never shared anywhere in the world
um
how do you do all that
how do you do all that is because I
really work and obsess on the needle
movers in my life rule number eight is
find real happiness with Brendan Richard
one of the speakers that night asked a
question I don't know what to talk about
tomorrow and I said Just remember this
most people come in this event in some
form of pain
they're hurting and it breaks my heart
that I actually know that to be true but
I do know that to be true it's one of
the things that I'm always very
cognizant of when I speak is that
there's a lot of people in here in some
pain
and
I'd like to make a dent in that in the
universe you know so I'm curious with
the brilliant people and you are
brilliant that I know
why you think more people aren't happy
and what could one do to just begin the
Journey of loving living and mattering
more and being happier
oh I love that
um I think let's begin with most people
don't know what happiness is or where
they get it
you know I I I taught this at your event
it's a simple framework it's like draw
out a triangle for those who are
listening draw out a little triangle and
on each of the points I'll tell you what
happiness is like the human desire and
striving is we want to sense aliveness
so you need to do more things that make
you alive make you a vibrant authentic
expressive uh make you sense an example
of that would be give me more for some
people it's adventure go mountain biking
okay it's like wow that just brought me
back to life you know some people it's
hanging out with great friends some
people it's doing their passion some
people it's uh you know just just
honestly feeling and sensing the moment
and meditating okay another thing that
everyone wants is connection most people
today lack the depth of happiness
because they uh I love what you said
earlier the difference between you and
maybe Tony is that you really believe in
the environment and most people lack a
connection with other people their
surface level relationships you can't be
really happy long term with service
level relationships so you gotta find
out how do I connect more deeply and it
can be simple things like you talked
about you know with the kids maybe less
than the texting call them have that
moment of connections nothing crazy
that's what you're striving for you want
happiness with your kid you're going to
call them you're going to connect with
them so think about connection
relationships a level of depth
then we want meaningful Pursuits
when I when I go after that
I just I love that Pursuit and notice it
doesn't say meaning a lot of people just
say meaning I said no it's meaningful
Pursuits because a lot of people we know
who are really successful they've
already had a meaningful life they're
miserable because they're not pursuing
anything anymore gosh Brandon that's so
true you got that we gotta have that
Pursuit man you gotta find a Pursuit it
has meaning to you it brings you back to
life that's happiness and then the
middle of the triangle is the capital G
growth
if you don't have aliveness you don't
have connection you don't have
meaningful Pursuits and you have growth
you're miserable we can Bank on it we
can guarantee it the research will
reveal it every single time but if we
can get you a little bit more alive a
little bit more connected a little bit
more meaningful Pursuits and a little
more growth
those like a little bit in each of those
it's like a thunderous
shift in your life you're just like whoa
little bits in those but there's an
access point
why are most people happy let's say they
do all those things
still not happy
and they're just not here
um
presence is the gateway to happiness
I can't get your present to feel it to
sense it can't change what most people
want in real like what they really want
all the people I work with maybe the
people you work with what they really
want
they'll never sit and almost of them
never know it what almost every human
being wants is they want to feel the Day
More
they got all these activities they're
blazing through get the kids to school
get this off to there get that done
answer that email get this project done
and even if they're moving towards
things they find meaningful and they're
awesome but if they don't feel it
if they're literally not present they're
not mindful enough to sense it to
appreciate to feel grateful to feel the
joy to feel the ups and feel the Downs
to feel the miseries to feel the winds
if you aren't feeling the day you're
just blazing through as an automaton
you're just blazing through the days you
know on autopilot you're just like
overwhelm stress going through it but
you don't feel
the day
I can't get you to be happy so the
gateway to all of happiness is always
presence learn to be more present in the
moment feel the moment even the bad ones
you gotta feel the day more so that when
you get on your knees at night to pray
you felt the day dear God thank you I
felt this day I felt those lessons you
gave me I felt those gifts you gave me I
felt thank you for that connection see
when you talk to God if you don't feel
there's there's not a relationship there
God wants you to feel it's way it's the
unique thing he gave us not just the
emotional reaction of an animal but the
ability to deeply appreciate feeling
very human so we've got to tap people
back in the present to deeply appreciate
the moments the feelings the events of
life again and I think that's why I'm so
happy it's like I feel so much most
people are so scared of that I'm like I
love it it makes me feel alive right how
do you sense more aliveness you got to
feel today Feel the Moment rule number
nine is improve your communication with
Brian Tracy the ability to communicate
well with others is one of the most
important skills you can possess and it
is a learnable skill as much as 85
percent of the success you achieve in
your life will be determined by how you
interact with other people because
communication helps people understand
each other better and better that's why
it's important to master all elements of
communication they include who is
sending the message and who is receiving
it or the speaker and the listener
moments of communication also include
environment noise context feedback and
the mode of communication itself
here are five basic rules that you need
to follow to master all elements of
communication
the first rule is to understand your
audience who are they where are they
coming from what concerns them what's of
interest to them what they need and want
to learn from you
no matter who you're speaking with your
boss your co-worker a group of people or
your own family everyone communicates
and receives communication differently
in order to master communication you
must be flexible with your communication
Styles and be able to adapt to who
you're communicating with in order to be
effective
understand your Audience by getting to
know them listen to them what is
important to them what are their pain
points or concerns in life what
motivates them
use this information to choose the words
you would like to use your tone of voice
and the topics that you'll speak about
the second rule to mastering the
elements of communication is to think
before you speak
you know a world of constant noise and a
rising number of voices you want to make
sure that you are heard and the best way
to ensure your voice doesn't get lost is
to think clearly and understand what you
want to say before you say it
think about what you want to say who
you're saying it to and how to best say
it in order for it to stick and for
communication to transfer seamlessly
from you to your audience to keep you
fully understand what message you want
to share before you actually share it
spend some time researching it thinking
through your topic and planning your
delivery
rule number three is to be transparent
and admit what you know and what you
don't
when we want to see ourselves as
effective communicators sometimes it's
hard to admit that we don't have the
answer to something we don't have the
answer to everything we shouldn't have
the answer to anything and if you don't
know something or uncomfortable sharing
your voice on a subject it's okay to say
that you don't know or that you don't
know yet
it's better than trying to Fumble your
way through an exchange that could cause
confusion and an even greater lack of
effective communication
a person that you're speaking with that
you do not know the full answer now but
you will find the answer and get back to
them within a specific time frame
then follow up by doing your research
and returning to them with a well
thought through answer
following this process shows that you
are genuine and builds trust both of
which are essential leadership traits
and qualities
the fourth rule to mastering the
elements of communication is to adjust
your environment your environment is a
big part of an effective communication
Exchange
example trying to ask your boss for a
raise for all of the hard work that
you've been doing during the middle of a
holiday party may not be the best
environment to communicate your message
a meeting during normal business hours
will likely be a more beneficial
environment for communicating your past
successes and the deservingness of that
race to you
so when you're trying to effectively
communicate to anyone about anything
plan when and where you will deliver
your message
reflecting on the things you learned
while getting to know more
about your audience will also help you
to understand the most optimal
environment to communicate with them in
the final rule to mastering the elements
of communication is to keep studying it
and seeking Improvement
communication is a skill set learned as
time moves on no matter how good you get
there will always be room to learn and
improve and grow
the more you practice and the more you
keep up with your new audiences mediums
and methods of communication the better
that you will get
after communicating a message to someone
try asking for feedback so that you can
continue to learn and grow and apply new
methods the next time you deliver a
message or story
try new methods of communication to
improve how your message is both
delivered
received
when you're able to communicate
effectively with others you have the
power to create positive change and
harness success in every aspect of your
life
all successful leaders have learned how
to master the elements of communication
practice these five rules and you'll be
well in your way to mastering the
communication skills that will open
doors for you and Rule Number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is become a good decision maker
with Eric Thomas you got to become a
good decision maker to make your dreams
become a reality so I made a decision I
was going to wake up every single day
and I was going to write
I was gonna wake up every single day do
me a favor in your phone right now I
want you to write down good decisions
bad decisions all right good decisions
bad decisions I want you to write that
down good decisions say with me good
decisions mad decisions so let me just
say this to you and I want to make this
clear all right I remember you know
years ago we used to say when we was
kids you know somebody would say well
that person is middle age that person is
old right you can't say that anymore why
because of the decisions that a lot of
us are making now there are kids who are
17 and 18 who are old why because
they're not going to make it to 19.
so they're seniors
like that's it in 1920 they're making
some bad decisions they're not gonna
make it to 21. so they're actually a
senior citizen at 15 because they don't
have three or four years left to go does
that make sense because they made what
kind of decisions bad decisions so
here's what I want you to do for me I
want you to ask yourself every single
day are the decisions I'm making good
because if you're a good decision maker
it means you are going to get you are
guaranteed to make your dreams become a
reality I told you my goal was to write
a book and make what list
New York Times bestsellers list in week
one we made it why because of the
decisions we made there was a whole lot
of decisions that it took to get here
and so in order for you to make your
dreams and goals become a reality you
got to be a great decision maker does
that make sense and listen to me every
every
outcome you get
I had an uncle who died of cirrhosis of
the Livery it didn't happen by accident
it did happen by accident he died maybe
50 60. it wasn't by accident how do you
die of cirrhosis of the liver
what for the most part what happens
somebody said drinking drinking what
you're not drinking water
you're not you're not drinking water
like you I'll listen to me very closely
you don't drink a gallon of water a day
and then 15 20 years later Dr Clark said
you got cirrhosis of the liver
but you drinking too much water
take the water and it's just messed up
your liver as a matter of fact if you
drink a gallon of water a day
you're actually your organs are going to
be cleansed and your blood is going to
be pure does it make sense but when you
drink alcohol I'm not telling you to
drink or not to drink I'm saying it's a
decision and certain outcomes come with
decisions
so I'm not telling you don't drink I'm
not telling you don't smoke you grown
you do whatever you want to do but I'm
telling you with every decision comes a
result with every decision that comes an
outcome
[Music]
you don't have to eat vegetables if you
don't want to but I promise you it's
your body's gonna at some point tell you
you're not eating vegetables does that
make sense so number one we're we're
going to become what kind of decision
makers good decision makers and then
hopefully we're gonna get to a a time in
our lives where we become what kind of
decision makers great decision making
and then one day I'm hoping that we at
least
so this book almost 300 pages in New
York Times bestseller the LA Times
bestseller USA Today that didn't happen
because I'm a genius it happened because
of some decisions I made
is that clear look if we don't do
anything else if you walk out of this
room today you owe you to make good
decisions because when you make bad
decisions you destroy you
you killing you
you're destroying you and I told you you
live in a country that if you make good
decisions you reap the benefits of it
you have to make a decision in your life
and this is
this is a decision and I would say that
it's a voluntary element of Faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so Faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe Faith sometimes
means putting a stake in the sand and
saying here's where I stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you you know pledge allegiance to a
friend you have a best friend and you
want to maintain that friendship as long
as you possibly can it's it's it's a
decision of Faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to university because
you could have done something else right
but you chose that so that's where you
put your faith
um and like I said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe okay so back to God is
love well I'm going to talk about being
first instead of God
um and being is the totality of
experience that we're going to Define
that it that way for the purposes of
this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature being is what you
experience as a conscious creature it
includes all your emotions all your
motivations all your subjective
experience as well as everything that's
objective Okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered it's a useful
move of Faith to act as if you love
being and if you love something then you
want the best in it to flourish and so
maybe you decide deep in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that makes everything
that's good better that that's the best
way to live to make everything that's
good better and maybe to restrict the
development of everything that's
malevolent and evil within yourself and
in the broader world insofar as you're
able to do that and so I think that's an
expression of Love is that because when
you love something you care for it and
the proper attitude towards being I
think is care
and so so that's one element of God is
love God being
analogous in some way to being
um now we could look at God more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being as good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and
maybe that's the most effective means of
having existence open its heart to you
so for example you know if you love
other people you want the best for them
you want the best and you deserve the
best in them if you love them and you
trust them courageously so you open
yourself up to them I don't think it's
unreasonable to assume that that's how
you elicit the best from them the best
that can be elicited you're going to get
hurt sometimes and betrayed but that's
going to happen no matter what approach
you take I think that's the most
effective approach and that is perhaps
the most effective approach to existence
per se to approach it with love and
courage and and so that's how that looks
to me
is it a feeling like loving a person yes
I think it is I think it is a feeling
like loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for a child your child your
your brother your sister a family member
it's the generalization of that to the
broader domain of of existence to
broader domain of domains of existence
and I think that's a skill in some sense
right I mean if you're good at loving
and caring for your family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that it's
very difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable it
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that and so you see that when
you have a job or you and you encounter
a boss who takes you under his or her
wing and helps develop you or you find a
teacher who's particularly inspiring or
you work for an entrepreneur who's
inspiring and who also opens doors for
you
um they're acting with love as far as
I'm concerned they want the best in them
to serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and that's
the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for God's sake
so can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a sophisticated
question
I don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness and sort of a cold
virtue I don't know if it balances out
the crushing responsibility but I think
it's the emotional analog to the
crushing responsibility right so maybe
there's love and Duty and and they run
parallel in in if you're an ethical
person that's not all there is to ethics
but you know love and Duty they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities you have to learn to
practice presence
practice presence being here fully in
the moment alive vibrant or at least
attentive right snapping your brain out
of that reactive like uh go with the
flow mode to know and being here
that oldest advice in all of personal
development about presence and awareness
about being with the flow about being in
the moment there's every spiritual
tradition has taught it as being Central
to human happiness and connection
this has been stolen from us because of
this I really believe I I I'm stunned
when I hang out with people that they
can't be present for three minutes
without wanting to scroll through
something I mean they can't be I mean
even four or five minutes they can't do
it anymore because they have trained
themselves with millions of swipes
to be not present
and I believe that meaning and
fulfillment
um they become too fleeting
when we haven't learned to be really
present
and I think that's important learning to
be really fully present
and pulling that from ourselves there's
plenty of times I mean if you saw my
schedule you're like how do you get
present I'm like I've trained myself
otherwise I can just be pulled in the
next thing there's always a million
things going on around me and I have to
learn to just zoom right in and be here
with you
you have to teach yourself to do that
too
because the more days that Blur by the
less sense of meaning or fulfillment you
have you can be busy but the days don't
Blur by
right I'm incredibly busy I'm actually
this last two years I can't believe how
busy we got but during that time present
forcing myself each day to get present
so I can recognize and appreciate those
little moments so I can create the
connection with other people
so that I can sense that spiritual
aliveness of being here now versus
hoping one day to arrive to something
and that that practice of cultivating
presence of I would say and I know
people don't like when I use this phrase
but demanding presence I demand of
myself to be present I because I know
when I'm not I'm like Brendan get
present okay so I might bounce in place
take 10 deep breaths just to reset my
brain and my body
and that 10d maybe you do it right now
with me just stand up wherever you're at
bounce in place a little bit take 10
deep breaths
re-center yourself to the moment and
keep going
and that way you can observe life many
people they'll work their whole career
then they'll retire and then they'll
retire and they'll finally be like oh
wow look at the color of the trees this
is amazing wow life looks pretty good
and they didn't even see it for five six
years they missed all of it even though
they were amidst all of it they just
missed it you have to teach yourself to
be with it to be here meaning and
fulfillment is so much as much as we can
Define it and have a destiny mindset we
can feel it
like I do it for like if I have a great
dinner with Denise like things go great
we just have a nice conversation I'll
walk away and I'll might be like putting
things away and just literally thinking
my mind
what a blessing
God I made it
thank you so much for this blessing to
be here with my wife what a great day
what amazing moment we just had you know
what years later I'm going to cherish
that dinner
simple as that it's what we say to
ourselves
in the minute and after the minute that
really defines how we feel over the long
term isn't true
I mean the little moments if you can
celebrate them be there for them give
thanks for them I believe the more you
give thanks for the moments in your life
the more meaning you find
the more you give thanks for the moments
in your life the more you feel fulfilled
even if you feel years away even if the
next big thing is out there it's okay
right now you're feeling it that's what
presence is it's about feeling the day
more you hear me teach this now for what
20 years like you have to learn to feel
life
if we don't feel it then what's it about
and you're not just going to suddenly
one day feel it you know because you
drink a bunch of coffee maybe you are
but you're you're gonna you're gonna
imagine me uncapping one day you're just
gonna you're gonna teach yourself to
feel the day and feel the moments more
you're going to observe more you're
going to breathe more
you'd have more intention and as you
learn to feel the day when someone says
hey you feel fulfilled about your life
you're like I do
because you are filling life
with presence when you fill life with
presence you feel full filled
it takes an active participation on your
point you're not just gonna show up one
day and feel fulfilled you have to fill
the day
with those senses of gratitude and
meaning and really
um I would say connection
if you don't do that I promise the days
just Blur by and the more they Blur by
the more you just stack on everybody
else's reactions needs desires drives
distractions their meaning and one day
you show up and you're just
you're really just a bag of everyone
else's intentions and needs and drives
and labels and meanings
and in that place
you're not autonomous
in that place
you don't get to experience that
individual sense of meaning and
fulfillment we've talked about from the
very beginning because you didn't take
the time to Define it consistently
enough the Dallas Uber driver oh so as
somebody who has gotten into
countless Ubers and some small
percentage of them know who I am and
then of course they start asking
questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
um yeah the Uber driver in Dallas that's
in this book
um I get choked up when I think about
him uh an aha I choked up I get choked
up because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day you've got millions and millions of
people that are inspired by empowered by
impacted by your content there are
people out there that use your work as a
lifeline
and it is humbling and what I am
really present to in the work that I'm
putting out and the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own struggles
is just how much people are holding
themselves back and how much pain people
feel
because most folks know what they dream
about
and what they want
and yet they're spending all of their
time and energy arguing against what
they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
I hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment but it's not
going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going I got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go
I don't know if I'm worth it I don't
know if right now is the right time to
do this I don't think I'm good enough I
failed so many times I can't go through
that door
and that's the problem I want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you and you are
actively arguing against it you're
bringing yourself down you're beating
yourself out like people will cheer for
you and me they won't cheer for
themselves
I'm the same way and so this Uber driver
the story that you're talking about I
get into the car and we start driving
and I'm on the phone as we're driving
and I'm having a conversation with
somebody about this daytime talk show
that I launched which was a dream with
Sony Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one it was a
huge failure because we didn't make it
to season two
huge failure in real world terms massive
success when it comes to the timeline of
my life and so I'm talking to this
person about the talk show I hang up the
phone and this Uber driver comes alive
he's like oh my gosh I can't believe
you're in my cab and I'm like why and he
says because I I want to talk to you
about something I think you can help me
and I'm like great how can I help you
and he says I have a dream of being a
oscar-winning uh actor and creating
opportunities for other black and Latino
men to do the same in acting and I'm
like freaking fantastic what the [ __ ]
are you doing in Dallas right yeah the
guy's 25 and so I I go you know the game
is in New York and L.A I mean sure you
can act you can write stuff you can be
here in Dallas but why are you not in La
why are you not in New York and he's
like you're right you're right you're
right I need to move to LA like why not
and he says I have 700 in my bank
account I'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car dude
drop me off and get driving what are you
waiting for and so we have this whole
conversation and I write about it in
this book where I am actively arguing
for his dream and he is actively arguing
against his dream
and what is so sad is throughout this
conversation Tom he's like you're right
700 could get me there you're right I am
only 25. you're right if I keep thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about what I want to be doing I'm not
only going to drive in circles my whole
life is going to spin in circles as I
think about what I want and I don't do
[ __ ] about it and then you are going to
find yourself not at 25 but at 45 or 65
and you're going to be so filled with
regret that you never put a put a bet on
yourself
and so this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
California and me giving him a bunch of
tools that I talk about in this book and
the point of the story is does he move
or not I don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves
discipline is your missing ingredient
you've got the heart you've got the care
you've got the desire to serve you know
you could be doing more you want to do
it for the right reasons you're not just
here to make money you're here to have
an impact in the grow and do amazing
things you know you can do amazing
things what's missing discipline
this is a lack of follow-through it's
the constant start and stop and start
and stop and start and stop and
for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing
somebody who's got so much talent and so
much potential and so much of a heart
and just seeing them not win because
they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent
enough work that you're motivated and
inspired and then and then you're not
anymore and nothing happens and
one of the only things that saved me the
only one of the only reason why I'm here
making these videos and you're watching
and I've had any you know success in
social media is because I just was
disciplined that I just kept making
videos one of the things I love sharing
is my journey of YouTube because I was
not an overnight success story
every month almost I'll post to my
socials of how I grew month over month
year over year on YouTube and in the
first five years I had 7 000 subscribers
or so
so five years in five years in of making
content
seven thousand subscribers
a lot of you are already ahead of that a
lot of you
could get there a lot faster than me
you know how do you keep going when
you're not getting traction when in year
one you have a hundred subscribers
I I just had to discipline to keep
making content to keep following through
and 12 000 videos later here we are
and and people can get there faster you
don't have to be as slow as me you know
I took I took a long time and I had a
lot of issues I was shy and secure and
introverted and felt like you had to be
you know type A personality to win and
all of these all of these limitability
all sorts of issues and you can get
there a lot faster than me but it still
requires a discipline to follow through
and do it and I really think it's one of
the only things that saved me
I remember sitting down at a
Florida outlet mall and I was sitting
there with uh with a friend and Nina was
going shopping and uh we spent half an
hour at a at a Starbucks there while she
was shopping and he said I'm gonna be
the next garyvee of my mystery it was in
music I'm going to be the next garyvee
in music and uh
You're Gonna Keep doing your thing like
let's me you know let's let's keep in
touch and see how we do and how we grow
and he posted
you know three or four years later
on his Instagram and he said you know
three or four years three or four years
ago I met Evan Carmichael at this Outlet
Mall in Florida they had our picture as
the as the host and I told him I was
gonna be the next garyvee for music and
he's gonna do keep doing his thing and
and Evan went on and did his thing
and I stopped
I didn't have the success that I said I
was gonna have
and here's the thing this guy has
way more Talent than I do and he's a
super talented in music and just better
camera presence
more energy
uh more his videos just look better way
more attention to detail he had all of
this stuff and and like a warm amazing
human who cares and wants to serve and
wants to see musicians make money and
turn their art into something amazing
right like he had all of this stuff
all of it
the only thing he lack was discipline
and he didn't follow through and and I
see that in so many of you
you've got everything you've got all the
ingredients
that's just a lack of discipline and not
making enough
it's the it's the lack of because you're
not motivated you stop and lack of
motivation isn't a good enough reason
you have to follow through
so how do you do it how do you how do
you uh how do you stay disciplined how
do you stay focused when you're not
getting results when you're not seeing
the wins how do you stay disciplined
okay so let me give you a couple things
first is having a really powerful
morning routine
this is a struggle for entrepreneurs
because no matter how great a day you
had yesterday today is a new day no
matter how great today is tomorrow's a
new day it's like you're starting over
every day you go to an event or you
watch a video get all inspired and you
expect it to last and then tomorrow you
wake up it's like oh how come I don't
feel the same way as I did yesterday and
then that creates a cycle of
procrastination instead of actually
following through so the morning routine
really matters what is it that gets you
feel inspired motivated
creative ready to go so that you go off
and have a much better day for me
two of the things that I find the most
valuable are in my morning routine one
is music so I put on music right away
it's the fastest way to change your
state put on songs that make you move
that make you dance and make you wanna
just change your state because you wake
up tired and no energy like let's go we
gotta demand Excellence from ourselves
and so music is the fastest way to get
your body into a different state
um
and the second in my morning routine is
to do a believe walk and that's 20
minutes to an hour every day I walk I go
to Tim Hortons I grab a cup of coffee
and spend you know two bucks on it and I
think about my day how do I want my day
to go what how do I want to be
intentional about the day so we're not
waking up like an accident most people
wake up like an accident fall into their
day look at other people load your phone
right other people's agenda for your
time and then you don't follow through
and so having that as part of my morning
routine really helps me so what is your
morning routine the most important thing
that you need to do is the thing that
makes you feel important vibrant that
today's gonna matter
put that into your morning routine
instead of hoping that it happened
that's why I make so many videos too
there's content for you every day if you
need me in your life or you need the
people that I profoundly there's
something every single day for you
across my channels so there's no excuse
for you not to get the the inspiration
and the motivation and the tactics that
you need to make your dreams happen so
that's step number one is have have a
powerful morning routine step number two
is create a calendar you know what's in
your calendar I'm making videos today
because it's in my calendar today's a
Tuesday when I'm recording this and
Tuesday is my YouTube day
there's a lot of stuff happening in my
life there's a lot of stuff happening in
my business uh you know right now we're
at um my my wife's parents house and
they're delivering a couch
see that they're delivering a couch here
to delivering a couch and they're
helping I'm here making content because
Tuesday is my YouTube day you know
there's so many other things I could be
doing right now
if I was left to my own devices I'd say
I have something more important to do I
need to be doing X
but because this has been scheduled in
my calendar I'm going to follow through
and make videos
how have I made you know 12 000 videos
because it's in my calendar it's been in
my calendar for years to make videos
so create a calendar especially with the
things that you know you need to do that
you're afraid to do I'm still afraid to
make videos guys you know again 12 000
videos later I'm still afraid to make
videos why because I want these videos
to be the best I've ever done because I
want to show up with more care more
heart more passion I hope that this is a
video that forces you you know to take
some kind of action I wanted to be the
best one that I've done and so I I'm
mini procrastinate before making videos
on a Tuesday every week I have a mini
mini procrastination the only difference
is my procrastination is you know 10
minutes instead of days 10 days and then
it doesn't happen right and so whatever
you are procrastinating on that you know
is important that you're just afraid of
you put it in your calendar and you
block off time and that allows you the
creativity and the space and suffocates
the excuses
for you not to follow through and then
step number three so one have a morning
routine right that sets you up to create
that gets you inspired makes you feel
like you're important today is going to
matter two you create a schedule for
when you're gonna do the things
especially the scary things on your list
and then three you have to teach
yourself that you do the things that are
in your calendar
you said you're gonna do it you put in
your calendar you get it done even if
you're tired even if you feel
overwhelmed you can change your calendar
for tomorrow or you can change your
calendar for next week
adult
trust yourself or listen to yourself
when you're feeling low when you're
feeling overwhelmed and you said you
were gonna do it
you have to go up and do it to teach
yourself because what happens is the
next time you say you're going to do
something you put in your calendar you
don't trust it you're going to follow
through because you haven't followed
through the last 20 times
so be very careful about what you put
into your calendar and when it's in
there you have to go off and do it
make those three changes in your life
morning routine
create a schedule do what's in your
schedule
the only thing you're missing is
discipline again you've got the heart
you've got the creativity you've got the
passion you've got the willingness to
serve you know you can do more you want
to create an amazing life for yourself
your family the people around you like
you know you've got this thing is you
know you've got this thing I don't need
to tell you this you know that you've
got something amazing inside you
and yet it's not happening consistently
enough you have to stop jumping from
high to high to high and and wondering
why you don't feel motivated today
there's nothing wrong with you this is
normal foreign
discipline
put it into your life and watch your
entire life change
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn the morning habits to
start your day productively check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there if you struggle with
anxiety with depression if you have a
hard time getting out of bed in the
morning slithering is something I want
you to try it is a pharmaceutic therapy
and it's going to change your life it
changed my